we're going to head towards our panel so
uh just hang in there if you would while
we gather our panelists again for those
of you that are on the panel if you
could go ahead and join back in we would
be most grateful I thought the the
audience might be interested in our
statistics from our two days I'm going
to put this in chat just so you can all
kind of absorb what we've had here we
have had more than thousand users
registered for the event
eight speakers from India five different
speakers from Africa and 14 from the
Americas so man everybody's been
mentioning diversity here and there
that's a lot of diversity so we really
appreciate that
um also we've got
um one more reminder about the learn dot
on
logixomxlogic.com for your free learning
portal account it's free
sets you on a path to learning so if you
haven't done yet I'm going to put the
link back in chat one more time as we
head towards our panel and you can get
that before we close
over the last two days we've had amazing
presentations and today we've covered
diverse topics from cancer forensics
space to Beauty drug Discovery to
basician hierarchical phylogenic trees
and what brings us all together is our
appreciation of the increasing role that
bioinformatics is playing in biomedical
research and the need for high quality
bioinformatics education mentorship and
opportunities for students to
participate in research so thank you all
for all of this and we want to thank our
speakers once again from today
we will be sharing the recorded sessions
on our YouTube channel and since I seem
to be really good at plugging in links
to YouTube or and all that or there is
the link to our postings that we will
have and let's review our esteem panel
we have Dr April Wright Dr Emmanuel Ruiz
and Elia Brodsky who's stayed on with us
and panel we want to dig in on house
students this is all about the students
how students can learn about
bioinformatics and Advance biomedical
research across the nepe regions so who
wants to start with tidy data and what
it means to us all
yeah I can start
um I think uh
I think there's often a lot of hesitance
to try and get students to do any sort
of bioinformatics or computational
research
um you know people think oh it's gonna
be really hard the students aren't going
to understand it
um
and you know I'm not saying that it's
going to be easy but I use R in my
introductory biology class and we do
some you know basic linear regressions
to do things like understand organismal
scaling or think about how mutations
move in a population
and
um
you know most students are game to try
things like that's that's what they're
really good at trying stuff
um and so I think
you know if we think it's important to
get students involved in learning these
sorts of skills and to uh get them to
think quantitatively consistently you
know we're the ones at the front of the
classroom
um so you know there's no one else who's
going to do that if we're not gonna do
that
yeah fascinating thank you Emmanuel
foreign
the possibility to to learn uh the basic
tools of bioinformatics uh I think is uh
quite crucial and
interesting in a way that firstly I
think it will uh
houses that illustrate all the theories
that he's learned on stats on mathem uh
mathematics statistic courses in
University and it gives a wide examples
of how what we learned in classes can be
used and be useful for being
um
global global topics and
um I think it can help them
practice this theory that they learned
and
um
and and yeah we need to try I mean
uh we need to to students need it it's
easy I mean it doesn't need a
a Big Brand to begin to learn uh
bioinformatics it's um has I say and
with the omnic logic tutorials that help
very much it's quite easy to learn with
internet and how to use the basic of
bioinformatics and
um with this
simple examples of how can be useful
it's a it's quite interesting to uh to
learn
sorry it's I think it's also very much
important because
more today we know with all these media
crazy stuff
um learning bioinformatics biologistic
help to see that all the information
maybe are not very significant but we
need some
tools to select what can be significant
and can be kept after so it's a kind of
also a kind of
mindset that is learned to be more
[Music]
um
I had to say that more
I don't know how to say that but
um
[Laughter]
I'd like to help you but I don't want to
put words in your mouth you can have
like that I don't see it so yeah
yeah more um take a step back of what we
think and before to confirm and give a
big conclusion for anything we can use
tools that have to say oh maybe not it
was not true it may be but in the end
it's not true so we have to be careful
and bioinformatics help to teach this
kind of mindset
okay Elia I'm going to let you uh kind
of close that up if you want to say
anything more about it and then talk
about how students uh and diversity of
experiences lead that off too well I
think here we have a great diversity of
experience right April was saying how
she did uh you know a degree in biology
and and then went on to journalism and
ended up doing what she's doing now so
it's it's the very non-linear path from
you know where you start where you end
up and we had a lot of speakers that
illustrate that I mean people that
um you know maybe started in a
completely unrelated space end up doing
bioinformatics now what does that mean
for students I wonder I wonder if it is
easier for them to see how
bioinformatics can be a useful and not
an intimidating uh skill set if they are
exposed to it early on
and not necessarily only after they said
I will you know master bioinformatics
and become proficient at it right how
can they do that how can they just try
something small you know in Us in an
elective course or maybe a mandatory
course but not with a high stakes you
know not like you either succeed or fail
you know there's a lot of in between and
um maybe another thing is uh diversity
from the perspective of this um this
kind of a community right I think when
you are just like three people that do
something it's also very difficult right
you gotta see that there is a a greater
population of people in in different
regions uh in different Universities at
different levels that maybe use this in
a variety of ways so I think that it's
very important to bring that Community
together and let students see each other
and kind of realize that you know it's
not just one single type of people that
end up doing this
foreign
I've heard over the last two days is how
diverse and how diverse the paths have
been so yeah April I'm sorry go ahead oh
yeah I was just gonna say I think one
thing that um
uh
is worth remembering is that you know
when it comes to who can see themselves
doing computation you know almost every
high school offers biology
right
a much smaller proportion of schools are
going to offer
advanced mathematics computer science
these sorts of things and so I was
writing a grant last year and I came
across this stat that you know 90
something percent of students who major
in computer science had it in high
school and I was like wow that's
incredible and then I realized well
probably 100 of students who major in
biology probably had biology in high
school right and so if we restrict this
sort of information on this sort of
training to people who have already
declared an interest in it we're
basically restricting this sort of
information in this sort of training by
ZIP code in a lot of places uh and so I
think yeah that integration like Elia
mentioned in lower divisions that
integration in coursework where it might
not necessarily be you know the
bioinformatics course but it's something
that everybody has to take uh I think
it's probably a good a good thing if we
believe all students should have access
to these skills
mm-hmm
any expansion on that Emmanuel
yeah no I don't know but um yeah it's
true it's true that bioinformatics is so
diverse that it will um
even for the undergraduate students that
uh she don't know exactly how they want
to evolve in their career and how they
want to specialize the they will have
tools that can help them
um very easily because bioinformatics
have a it's a very very diverse and
these tools also can be used for other
or the same tools can be used for other
[Music]
field has Finance business or other
other activities so it can be quite very
useful and and yeah and we are
I imagine because it's a long time a
happy new student but uh we try to be in
the top of Technologies and right now
biology uh uh have been so is so hyped
that uh
into technology are very high tech and
so it should be very interesting for the
students to to have an access of what
how
this new biology are because of
bioinformatics impact so it's um
it's yeah
so one of the things I could imagine a
student having a hard time asking
questions and going beyond the guide
Direction and going self-directed and
coming up with creative thinking if you
don't know how to ask questions how do
you ask questions can can you guys talk
about that a bit
helium
well I think that's kind of what's
missing in bioinformatics right
bioinformatics is almost viewed as this
like set of skills you know you know how
to code you know how to do this you know
that so if somebody gives you a coding
problem and they explain to you you know
this is what you need to do this is kind
of the result I'm looking for you know
it should look like this I think yeah
anyone can follow that it's much more
difficult I think for students uh to
feel like they can be creative and and
kind of thinking Beyond those kinds of
instructions
and even sometimes spot what they are
finding you know what is interesting
about their finding because ultimately
as a student you know you do a lot of
digging right and a lot of digging and
reworking your problems is because you
don't get them right
but as sometimes you kind of stumble
upon something that is interesting right
and and then sometimes your expectation
might be well you know maybe that was
another mistake uh but it's not always
like that right and so you have to
almost have
um that anticipation that every once in
a while you know you're going to stumble
across something that is interesting and
when you do you need to have I think a
good um way to explain what it is
communicate it to somebody who's more
experienced than you and have that
discussion of equals almost you know
like this is what I see in data what do
you see you know how is this like the
correct way to interpret that so I think
that's a skill that you cannot Master by
you know reading a textbook you almost
have to uh be mentored to be shown an
example that yes we all make mistakes we
all stumble across interesting findings
and that's what papers are is like we
found an interesting finding now let's
try to describe it and validate that
it's a real real thing
that's interesting that you mentioned
the aspect of digging because
you know
one of the things I feel like we teach
kind of poorly is
how to read scientific literature
right how to pick up the narrative and
how to understand it and
um
so I do some domain-based education
research and I have
um you know one class where we're
looking at kind of more straight lecture
versus if we incorporate more like
learning how to read a scientific paper
and then doing sort of Socratic method
uh discussions and I'm I'm really
interested to see how these data come
out
um because I feel like
you know one of the most common things
that I see in students is not that
they're they come into research and they
want to do things and it's not that
they're not bright or they're not
um you know intelligent people it's that
they stumble with the independence right
and it's like you learn to be a good
writer by reading a lot
right but when you learn to be a good
scientist you do that by sciencing a lot
but how do you do that in the
undergraduate curriculum in a way that
um you know we're constantly shuffling
them around right you're going to chem
lab and you're not a chemist so you have
a lot of instructions if you're not a
physicist you have a physics lab and a
lot of instructions and uh there's not a
lot of room for independent exploration
in a lot of these and so and you know
having them read the literature and see
how other people have done independent
exploration I think I think is really
important that's a good point
so uh Elia you kind of talked about
something about
um in the classroom and stuff like that
how much of that stuff uh how much of a
responsibility do we put on a mentor or
a teacher to make sure a student
understands it's okay to be wrong it's
okay to walk down the wrong path it's
okay to ask questions
uh well I I'm just going to incorporate
this message that I just see in chat um
from Dr Amitabh Jai aswal who's saying
as a bioinformatics learner my
difficulty is that I find it hard to
understand concepts of computer science
and statistics although I understand
biology fairly well but those things
instill loss of confidence and
consequently productivity also when I
approached some professors or
practitioners of the subject even they
don't truly appreciate the depths doing
a series of clickable of clicks or
following an algorithm does not impart
real understanding hold so this
disenchant so I I guess what you know
this message means to me is that whether
I mean uh Dr Jesse small here is not a
student right he's already an
established maybe a researcher and
learning bioinformatics right so I think
if you go into any new domain
you're going to be following somebody
else who's saying you know this is
pretty much the formula of how you get
from A to B right and I want you to be a
b and that'd be something else happens
right you get a degree uh now you know
we call you a doctor or whatever it
might be right so I think this kind of a
view of uh what you know research if you
want to be in research that's kind of
like a parallel uh world that you're
living in because in research one of the
more important things is getting to a
point where you know you stop relying as
much on other people that tell you this
is how you do things because otherwise
you find it difficult to kind of get
away from established truths which is
what you know you're going to end up
challenging in in most of your research
so I think that you know
um it's a it's something that is much
more advanced in the west than maybe in
some other more traditional
um you know systems of education so so
that does exist on the other hand I
think that the effort to get people
faster to this higher level where they
can become more independent could have
this downside that you know people view
this as restrictive so you know I think
that's where you have to kind of
Leverage the abundance of resources that
are available to you know skill uh you
know understand ask questions about how
things work and and get to that point
but you know it's not something that I
think you can get from that formal
education the goal of formal education
is probably not that
is something that I realize on my own
experience is sometimes
you don't have reserves or you have
results that you are not able to explain
that can be in biology but also in
bioinformatics yes but it's not because
they are wrong it's just maybe they are
largely more complex but we saw
initially and so we need maybe more time
or maybe someone else at one point will
find we understand it and so you need to
be to lower a bit the pressure of the of
the results and say okay bam maybe it's
more complex of what I saw but it's not
a wrong person uh yeah is that something
that you can help and not be completely
um discourage in the in the research
World
anything to add April no uh I have to
run and get my kids from school though
so um thank you for having me it was
really nice well thank you for being
here yet again
so uh nice to meet you uh Emmanuel as
well nice to meet you too thank you
Emmanuel and Elia what's uh coding in R
and python computational training are
those going together how important are
those things I've heard those names
throughout the last two days
I guess I wanna also ask you know what
Emmanuel thinks about it I started
learning R first and I really thought
you know this is so great you know you
can just produce these charts right away
they look nice you know you can just put
them in Publications it was really kind
of like an exciting simple way to get
quickly to meaningful results in Python
I mean just using matplotlib with all
the loops and trying to get your chart
to you know display different colors and
annotations that was such a pain
um until I realized that python maybe is
much easier in fact to use in other
domains like machine learning for
example I find it very easy and kind of
intuitive the way that those packages
have been built so I think that there
are benefits to you know either r or
python in different applications but it
is dependent on kind of where do you see
yourself going like if all you need from
R is to get that plot and everybody's
using that complex heat map to you know
produce that nice figure maybe that's
enough but if you are trying to go much
further beyond that build your own
application you know start kind of
working with other types of
um repositories here and there you know
that's I think where you have to know
enough of both to not be afraid and to
also be able to kind of you know
specialize eventually down the road but
you know I would be interested to know
what Emmanuel thinks about that
but I mean it's simple I'm still not in
Python
I am in r i well I imagine I am
familiana with r and I still
um
haven't find on my application the
limits of R where I couldn't use R but
um yeah so for me I was a
simple
I would say that I found the tutorials
that let me uh understand are in a
simple way and going step by step
um and so
um it's very useful as you say for um
for plots for simple analysis and um
like that in my head to be honest I
don't see Publications that show python
but most of them show that they have
done their analysis with r so um I think
it's very useful but
um
as you say we don't have to be close on
one software but see how others can be
also helpful and with the omic logic
tutorials I'm gonna begin to learn
python better new language I didn't know
initially I didn't want to do both at
the same time even if bioinformatician
attorney you need it but I was a bit
afraid that if I learned both at the
same time I will mix them and I will
don't succeed to to improve my skill so
I I stay on r
yeah nice nice so let's let's switch a
little bit of this over to the Social
and emotional aspect of research
especially as it applies to students now
I've heard in my world here how many
people throughout the last two days have
stumbled onto something that became
important in their lives but how much
impact do students have into research
and then what happens in our world
um you know I understand this topic to
be
um extremely important from the aspect
of research being very discouraging
sometimes right so I think that research
is a very long game it's not something
that you achieve results quickly and
it's something that you're going to fail
a lot more than maybe if your goal was
you know much less ambitious so so it's
definitely for people that have the
perseverance and the emotional strength
I would say or ability to you know
disconnect from their emotions to go
over uh you know overcome those
challenges so I think that's one part of
it the social part of it is that being a
scientist you you know you wish you were
the person on tedx talks you know
discovering uh you know things that
change the world but most of the time
you're not right so most of the time
you're kind of behind the scenes and
your pis who's out there talking about
the discoveries they've made in the lab
so I think that you know uh if you
um uh if you choose this area of
research and I think that's where
bioinformatics actually is going through
sort of a transformation you know I uh
my father is a bioinformatician and has
been for you know decades and so he was
always
um the one providing data to people who
went on on stage and you know talked
about the discoveries and I kind of saw
this disconnect between the hard effort
that he was putting into his analysis
work and whatever the biologist was then
presenting I think today that is
becoming much more balanced
bioinformaticians there was an article a
few years ago that bioinformaticians can
finally be in the driving seat you know
I I think that is a little bit of a
change in an encouraging change for
those that have chosen bioinformatics as
their science
yeah I agree with you that's a better
best quality of researcher are
perseverance uh because that's you you
will need it I mean because
it's maybe less than bioinformatics
maybe more on bench work but uh you
spend most of your time having negative
results before to have one positive
results and it's not something
um that is easy to manage so you need to
have perseverance
and um uh so uh uh I think there is one
thing that a skills that need to be
learned
and it's long process because it's more
kind of a routine to know how to
separate uh your professional life to
your personal life because research
doesn't have end
and it's like when we do a big puzzle we
don't want to stop until it's finished
but at one point we need to have also a
healthy life and a healthy separation
between what is research or professional
life and personal and that I think
honestly is a skill that need to be
learned
because it's not easy it's not uh innate
and more when we are students and we are
working for pi of a PhD postdoc when we
are working for people that better the
pressure is because they have their own
pressure okay it's not easy for them to
uh it's difficult to put this
um separation and maybe
learning this this these two skills
perseverance and separate uh
professional to personal life
um is very helpful to have a a success
in research and
yeah I think that as you say not every
researcher will have the Nobel Prize
but uh it gives us a kind of humility
and a kind of encouragement to know that
uh for another price there was maybe
thousands of manuscripts that these
numbers right I've read I try to
understand a used two is on projects
that have this reward so in a way our
work participate to the world science
evolution and that is a it's a beautiful
feeling
hmm fascinating so you guys touched on
something and I want to I want to kind
of go back to it for students in doing
all this research is there an issue with
expectation a result and I think you
kind of walked around a bit hit it a
little harder because I'm a new student
I know I'm going to find this and then
it's not even close
well I think actually uh one of the
speakers Dr Paulson mentioned that they
involve students it's almost like as a
pi you have to have this you know maybe
decades or years-long project and if you
are able to involve students at
different stages of this project you end
up sharing these exciting Milestones
with them that they feel like they've
gotten to a result so it is a lot of it
is about mentorship with an intent to
offer students not squeeze work out of
them but allow them to get into the
field and feel like they are
contributing something meaningful right
so like for example in my experience
I've had a number of very established
um pis that haven't included me in
Publications that you know I honestly
did not contribute maybe that much but
the fact that you know my my name ended
up on that publication you know gave you
like you know ah you know we published
in major you know whatever my
contribution was but you know that was a
very empowering uh feeling for me
I understand I understand it's uh yeah
we have similar experience yeah where we
are
where we work hard I know my PhD I mean
uh my principle project have not been
yet privileged so it was quite hard
because when we spent four years working
on it and by discovering new tools by
yourself I mean it was quite hard but
um
but uh what what I have done even if the
it didn't get published has a we wanted
it helped other teams to build their own
Pro their project and um and so uh uh
driving
um
and discovering more but uh their uh the
science and
the breast cancer at this time so yeah
it's it's
um it's frustrating I mean research is
frustrating it's not uh you don't have
to be blind and go there saying oh it's
a happy place it's a it's a frustrating
work but
um
but um yeah knowing that um even and
directly we participate to this
knowledge Evolution help to uh to
overcome these frustrations and um and
so to further pressure lower because
um unfortunately the success of
researchers are very dependent of what
they privilege and so when you work
years uh or months or years on projects
that uh in the end but you didn't see
any publication it's quite hard but um
there is other indirect way to to have
encouragement so it's uh it's nice to
remember that
you know very good well thank you all we
are wrapping our time here as it comes
to an end thank you all uh especially uh
Elia and uh Dr Manuel for sticking
around this afternoon and answering some
questions especially as as students
because I've seen a lot of student
questions in chat over the last two days
so thank you all to those of you in the
audience please engage with us I posted
our Social Links a little bit ago and if
you can comment and share there that
would really help our mission and of
course go sign up for your free account
that wraps up our two days of
international worldwide learning uh I'm
just stunned by the level of
intelligence and integrity with all the
researchers and speakers thank you all
thank you again Emanuel and Elia and
that wraps us up so thank you all so
very much